Hey what's going on.
It's Bill Burr.
It is time for the Monday morning
podcast for Monday July 9th 2018.
When a man loves you will
he'll do some dumb shit like get a ring.
Then all of a sudden he's
married he's like What did I do.
Did he will say Are you mad at me.
She'll just shake her hand and say no.
And then she'll treat you like
shit for the next five days
what's going on.
It never ends.
People never it's.
How are you. What's going on.
I'm out here in a heat wave.
I'm still getting over this
fucking ball that I caught.
I don't know what I have it you
know they're just lingering.
I'm just I'm all congested.
You know don't take it down.
Put it over your head and then sit behind
your car and have somebody stand it up.
All right. You make sure you
have a lemming in your mouth.
You know that's what it might swat my
fucking day has been like for the last
eight days.
Everybody has it's fucking hilarious.
All these people who
aren't pharmacists right.
All of these people have never
invented anything in their life.
I mean even just some dumb shit like
you you take some wire and you fucking
twist it. Then you bend it and it's
like look for nineteen ninety five.
It's your very own but it's
your right back massager
Yeah.
They've all been telling me how to
fucking cure this shit and it's just like
okay all right I'll Oh I'll try that.
Oh what you say zinc the man over there
in the plaid shirt says zinc What are
you what say you vitamin D.
You say vitamin D but you would say yeah.
I feel like I'm on a game show right.
When you are the price is right and
everybody's yelling out a price like a
different number and the person's
looking with their deer in the headlights
that's what it's like when
you have a fucking cold.
By the way me and my wife who
isn't mad at me who isn't.
Not not talking to me but isn't
actually really chatty either you know.
You know you get them out of that mood
you're happy you can't say it out loud.
You can't say I don't you know I don't
give a shit anymore at this point.
I've gone through enough hours of torture
here what you do is you just think you
know what.
I don't give a fuck.
And they are so smart they sense the
second you do that and then immediately
they want to sit down and talk about it
because once you give a fuck the game's
over okay.
And they don't want you to settle into
not giving a fuck because then you won't
be able to listen to their
lecture and nod and go OK.
Yes I will work on
that. OK. You know what.
I didn't know that. Oh I'll do I
do that. Is that what I do. Wow.
It's it's so great to have somebody
outside myself to let me know what it is
that I'm doing.
You know you're like a mom like just
going around my fucking the planet of my
head observing
not a moon honey.
May maybe be like a an alien aircraft
you know of higher intelligence.
Does that make you feel better.
Anyways it was on
godly fucking hot ungodly fuck it was
the hottest it's ever been it was like
palm desert out here it was 109 fucking
degrees on Friday and I'm not I'm not
even talking about in the valley.
Maybe that was the valley.
I don't know what it was but it
was like you were what it was like.
I feel like I was standing inside a dryer
and I've used that reference a lot but
this time was like Oh yeah I could dry my
clothes in this you know by the way
those idiots who like you could fuck and
fried egg on the sidewalk you could
probably do that when it's like 80 degrees
out.
You know I mean it'd be
like frying it on low.
I don't know what it would be like me you
know but like on Friday when I was 109
degrees out at around 2:00 in the
afternoon I like your shit would be over
medium before you even flicked it
then you wouldn't have to season it
because of all the rock salt right.
For those you back east
and so the inevitable happens is there's
then after human beings in their own
way have made it.
I don't know how many degrees
hotter but we have made it harder.
I think even scientists that wear red
coats a red ties even they have been like
you know we're kind of having
an effect on the environment.
I mean if gypsy moth caterpillars have
to be stopped I mean what about human
beings.
Say what you want
about gypsy moth caterpillars.
You know they they don't make you know
nuclear waste they they've never you know
invested in plastics you know they're
pretty green for what it is that they do
right and they are part of nature so
they probably really don't need to be
stopped by an outside force like us
we're stopping them for our own fucking
survival.
And the problem is his mother nature
up until this point has been bringing a
knife to a gunfight with like fucking
gypsy moth caterpillars it's some bullshit
like that and I think now she's realizing
that she needs to go down to the local
fuckin
what he called the place to go down to
the place where there's always like a bad
keyboard in the fucking window pawnshop
go down in the pawn shop she's gonna get
herself a fucking heater boner powder a
burner whatever the fuck you call them
and I'm fucking a boner she's going to
come out with a fucking dick move she's
going she's going to do a reverse Bruce
she's gonna fuck all of us in the ass
with the weather I think that that's sort
of a stretch to say I have no idea but
all I know was you know
it was fucking insane.
So the inevitable happens is then there's
a power surge there was like nobody on
the roads like that's how fucking hot
it was everybody was just staying inside
sitting in air conditioning
like Oh my God.
And that fucking guy out there and then
we all after making it harder you know
I'm not saying it wouldn't be
answered four degrees or whatever.
I don't even know if we made it
five degrees higher or whatever but
we sit inside and we don't get to feel
we don't feel the effects of what the
fuck we're doing. It's like buying
a shirt. You know what I mean.
You don't see the fucking 8
year old that sewed it together.
Does this shirt make me look good.
Right. It's like it's painless.
So now we're all sitting there in the
AC and inevitably we don't have enough
power.
So now they have to have a blackout.
Now where are they going to do it.
Okay now I already gave it away.
Okay.
The keyword here is Blackout
Black would be the keyword.
You know I don't you know where they did
it but I know they didn't fucking go.
Well we have to shut down the grid
somewhere. Where should we shut it down.
Should we shut it down in Beverly Hills
or fuckin Bel Air or these people with
their fucking infinity pools that fall
off into the goddamn ocean with their
panoramic views.
You can only see the
roundness of the planet.
You know
these people with their MTV Cribs
stocked fuckin refrigerators
they're giant carbon footprint or now.
Now
those people fund our campaigns.
Let's fuckin
let's if I can go down here.
These people who can barely rub two
fucking nickels together will shut down
their shit
just an evil fuckin world.
And oddly enough this weekend as I sat
in my air conditioned house you know not
in Beverly Hills but not the hood either.
You don't know me like if I was on a
chessboard I wouldn't be a pawn but I
wouldn't be in the castle either.
You know I don't think I'd be the horse
I wouldn't be a bishop I think I'd be a
rook you know basic forward sideways you
know weight gain no
lateral fucking movement
went dark diagonal I'd fucking trip over
myself or try to run a fuckin it or an
outright route like a fuckin horse I
would still think I'd make it you know
cause the fuckin bride can
do whatever she wants right.
John all the goddamn power at the fucking
king they'll just sit there back it up
Whoa whoa hey guys surround me she's
pissed she's pissed or she said she's not
pissed but she's not talking to me.
She is but you know what I
mean it's really quick and
serviceable conversation
would you like some dinner
okay. It's ready salmon
likes talking to nothing.
Anyways they should have like this is
such a hacky idea of what they should
literally.
I wish they had right now if they had
like a fuckin like a relationship to me or
someone must have done a bit like this.
Like you have like a relationship.
Meteorologist you know what I mean.
That could give you a
five day fucking forecast.
Let you know what kind of coat to wear.
Basically what kind of kind of
shit am I going to try to avoid.
So I don't step into it.
You know what I mean.
So anyways I'm in the fucking house right.
And
you know I got the kid now and she's
getting bigger and eventually she's going
to need her own room.
All right.
And I have all and I don't even have a
lot of shit but I have all I have a lot
of shit.
I didn't figure out a lot of shit.
I wrote a lot of furniture
but I have a lot of shit
you know just over the years going on the
road buying a little thing here little
thing their fan giving you something the
venue giving you something and all of a
sudden you just got a bunch of shit.
And then what happens is
if enough time goes by
Easter I don't know I'm sentimental.
I start to develop feelings for
it and it's hard to get rid of it.
Well
I don't have a choice now people.
So in the near future
I'm going to I am going to have a
massive massive fucking giveaway
of memorabilia and shit
and an old drums stuff.
And like you know I try to give some
people my my old drum magazines and just
nobody wanted them all these fucking young
kids are like you know I stick it out
and fold bra.
And is good fucking I can read
this on my phone like I like.
I don't know what like you'd think I was
handed and like a hammer and chisel in
a rock and be like you I
draw pictures with this.
So I didn't feel too bad because they're
made out of paper although I'm sure the
ink is bad for the environment.
But I I put like 20 years of all of these
fucking magazines that I saved like I
was going to go back and peruse through
two decades of fucking drum magazines
and I kept some of them you know
John Theodore's the fucking Nico brain
the fuckin Steve Jordan you know all the
way back all the drummers
and I fucking love right.
Tommy Lee you know but then you know
the latest ones were the easiest ones to
get rid of because I'm an old man and
I probably didn't know a lot of those
players although I probably should but
you know I don't know I just wish
I could go back in time and that by
anything you know Jimmy The Gent don't
what the fuck that I say don't buy
anything you know as much as he was
a murderous psychopath he was very
environmentally conscious in
that part of Goodfellas you know.
So anyways just giving you guys a heads
up I I got it all out in front of me
here. I got it all laid out.
My wife who's not mad at me
is.
You know she was like Well what
do you get like a storage shed.
You know you like this stuff and it's
like I'm not fucking doing that I'm not
doing that like whenever I
see those places I get like
I have a fucking almost a
physical reaction to them
when I see a storage facility.
And it's the second I did that
before and I fucking do with them.
You have to go back and
check in on your stuff.
It's like your stuff went
to jail and then you know.
You can just fuckin
hang on a second I got a
fuckin text escape back.
There's no way for me to continue talking.
Call you in
in a 45 minute
anyways.
This just
than you do in the George Carlin bit.
You just have shit just spread out all
over the fucking world and it's just like
if there's not like.
Fox shut up
all right.
If there's not Roman it in your house.
Like we have more rooms that
could be bedrooms and people here.
Okay. It's just me why I
want my wife for my daughter.
So there's no fucking reason why there
should be no room other than the fact
that we just have too much shit.
And I'm not throwing it out.
I thought the magazines because I made
out of paper and I don't obviously give a
shit about it but I'm really trying to
fucking think about where this stuff is
going to end up.
OK and
I don't know.
So I'm going to try to like you know I
figured if I could just take some of this
shit if you guys wanted.
You know I'll just fucking give
the stuff away or whatever.
I hope some people aren't going to get
mad cause some of the stuff is like shit
that venues have given me
you know some sports jerseys with my name
on the back of them and stuff which is
fucking cool or whatever but like you
know I'm not going Oh I'm not I never wore
it and I always appreciated the gesture
but I just took it and I put it in a box
and then I just started piling these
fucking things up and I don't know any
fuckin room I don't know
what to do with them so
my new fuckin thing from here on out
fifty fucking years old is Jimmy The Gent
I'm not fuckin buying anything I'm not
buying anything you know I'm trying to
get my wife on the same fuckin page but
you know you know that's not work it
ought to be Jesus Christ
telling her not to go on Amazon is like
her telling me not to get shitfaced on a
Tuesday I mean it's just not happening
by the way speaking of drinking I haven't
drank you wouldn't know it from my
voice sound like shit but I haven't
drinks at the end of June and
it's so it's so fucked up it's so
fucked up how it's just like food
I made the same relationship with food
that I have with booze that I do is I
just fucking walk away for a few days
what the fuck am I doing when I see food
walking away it's like sugar and shit
and bad food and I start eating well and
then all of a sudden if I look at bad
foods I want to fucking eat that and I
feel that way and I do the same thing
with booze like you know when I'm drinking
and I see a bottle of booze I swear to
God it's like you know it's backlit at
the bar I mean it just looks like you're
drinking life it just looks golden you
know so inviting and then when I just
stopped drinking I just looked at him like
Jesus I don't fucking mess with that shit.
What the fuck did I do now.
What I got to apologize for I know I'm
wrong that's the worst thing about it you
know what I mean
Jesus does it ever fucking end you don't
I mean it's like when I was a kid my
mother was mad at me and I didn't she
wouldn't tell me I got to fucking figure
out what I did
I love on all these fucking tv shows
where they sit there and they always sit
there they talk about how we're living
to see twice as many fucking words in a
day and how they got great
at communicating it's like
No they're not they're not
then I go to communicating.
They speak in fucking riddles.
Can you tell she's home.
I keep whispering so
speak in fucking riddles.
I'm so no body mind today younger right.
Now sit in a telephone like
to which you're going to
understand about a woman is
by the time they're eight they get
the whole fucking thing planned out.
Not all of them but enough of them.
He is still sitting there playing in
a fucking mud puddle or jumping off a
jungle gym going Hey Mom look what the
fuck I can do whatever kids do nowadays
you know fucking dancing with your
fucking toy robot whatever you guys do.
They got it all planned out.
That's why.
How many times guys have you been out
on a date with a woman and she said some
shit to you that sounded like a
riddle and you're like What the fuck.
And then you answer the question then
she goes I know you're supposed to say
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah.
Like I didn't know there was a script
nobody sent me the sides for my part like
they have the whole fucking thing
the whole fucking thing mapped out.
And you basically you have three options
you really just accept it
or die alone.
Or you go out by a wife
beater and you become that guy
and she don't want to do that
is he playing women it's a mythic village.
Shut up. God. Just fucking around.
You know I was on Twitter right.
And
Sony wrote some fucking hilarious
smart ass thing about me.
So I clicked on their profile because
I was just like you know that is above
average shit talk.
Is this another comic.
Is this an up and coming
comic I don't know.
I was like go with a comedian level funny
so I went to this person's thread and
I you know read a little blurb figure
what they did so I scrolled down to try to
figure out are they a comedian look for
a standup picture and one of the things
this person had retweeted was from this.
Something something feminist
was talking about Donald Trump
and
and was saying like Donald Trump just
made fun of the victims of me too and the
crowd roared with approval period.
And then again she wrote roared with
approval right and then she had the leg.
Oh my God oh my God are you kidding me.
This is what he did today.
This guy's fucking crazy.
So I clicked on it
and he made a roundabout
reference to me to
you know he was using me to the way
some people use millennials which is not
right.
I'm not saying it's right to do that
but you know I'm not trying to be a cunt
here but I am a comedian and
I've been on stage for 26 years.
They did not roar with approval okay.
He got a chuckle
he got a polite chuckle.
I'm not saying they weren't meat heads.
I'm not saying what he
said was back in right.
But the crowd did not
roar with approval period.
Roared with approval and it just as a
comedian that fucking annoyed me because I
went back in the day you'd
see these fucking comics
get offstage after I crushed
a fucking crushed NBC if I could.
You got the job done.
That's not telling.
You can't stop walking around saying
you killed it didn't Donald Trump didn't
kill OK.
If that was his fucking audition set for
a club and those were the laughs he was
getting.
They would say you know what.
He's he's not ready yet.
Well I'd say he's not funny.
He she she was getting some
laughs but he was all right buddy.
I don't think he's ready for a weekend
spot yet like he was getting like Monday
Tuesday level laughs.
Like back you know when there was some
sort of fucking system in the clubs when
they would actually build talent.
They used to have you know Monday was
like an open mike night at Nick's.
And then the big deal was your next move
and next time you stop in Boston the
next move was the host Billy Martin who's
now like you know one of the made men
over there at Bill Marshall.
He then had a show Wednesday night at
the Kowloon and that was the first big
fucking move out of the open mikes.
I got a spot at the Kowloon and you'd
say that to the other open makers in.
Did you just burn through the crowd of
open makers doing it for a burger spot at
the Kowloon.
And then I remember thinking like the
first time I did a spot at the Kowloon.
I was so fucking nervous because this
was the first time I went out in front of
a crowd that was not expecting
to see an open maker.
They did not go to an open
mike show going all right.
Let's see what these fucking people
have or I'm here to see a friend of mine
like they came out to see a comedy show
and they were like All right we're gonna
give you that we're gonna hand you the
keys for five minutes let's see what the
fuck you do right.
So I would say I would say that
that's where Trump was in that speech.
He was doing five minutes
at the counter all right.
This has nothing to do about
what the fuck he said or whatever
but I did find it interesting though.
But that's how she heard it.
She heard them roaring with laughter
Yeah like
anywhere you fucking elicit a Trump go
in fake news Fake news like it wasn't
necessary.
Well sometimes it's fake but it's more
just people hear shit and then whatever
they're passionate with it just it
raises the fucking levels you know
like you know with me this you know
you know you guys at this point if you
listened long enough you know
this shit that sets me off.
All right.
And like the amount of fuckin times I
lose my shit and I think it's go it's
going a certain way.
And then I find out not only am
I not right I am 100 percent.
It's a complete 180 it's
going in the other direction.
Now I'm not saying that this woman should
not have been upset you know and also
get upset that people chuckled you know
but they did not roar with laughter.
I'm just being a country
comedian right now.
You know there's just certain things
that people say that that goes into the
terminology terminology of a comedian.
And it bugs me.
Like the thing that I you know I talked
about a part a year ago or two years ago
was this fucking phenomenon where all
of a sudden people started saying I love
when the comedian heckled the crowd
it's like no no the community
doesn't heckle the crowd.
Comedian gets heckled a heckler goes
to a performance and tries to disrupt a
performance speech.
Anything that is a heckler all right
for a comedian to be heckling a crowd.
The crowd to be had to be collectively
giving some sort of fucking performance
that he he's interrupting.
All right.
You could say the comedian snapped a
loved one you fucking just lost your shit
on that go.
But I'm not heckling the crowd like
oh look at I you sit in your seats.
You call that a show. Sorry. Whatever.
So anyways how many documents and that's
24 minutes got them then a bad day pay
a bad at all.
Hey let's talk about World Cup soccer huh.
What's what.
You know Asia we talk about NFL football.
I know the theme song.
I don't know what the the World Cup thing
is you know but I've watched enough of
it that I know in the end they're
going to go to the wrap up with the
fashionable lady.
Then there's the old black guy looks
he's like you know fell off a stool at a
pub. He's probably some old
fucking football player you know.
And then there's the
excitable like sort of fat guy
who looks like you with the mustache.
You know that may allow to say Latino as
a white guy. I mean he is a latino dude.
He looks like the guy though when the
first guys that gets killed in a fuckin
mob movie
and then the other ones it seemed like
they just we had a revolving chair like I
recognized this black dude
with dreads as being like.
Wasn't he on our fucking Team
USA Team.
Oh by the way I finally figured out
how to fucking tell who the fuck is ho.
In a world cup game if you didn't get
there at the beginning this is how works
at American TV on Fox Sports they
basically right next to the team name.
They'll have the smallest little sliver
of color and that's the color of the
uniform like I watched Russia
first Croatia and I'm just
sitting there literally
waiting for somebody to fuckin score
so I can figure out who the fuck is who
have set their course you know if I can
get it all to three hours I'm kidding
man it was it was a fucking unbelievable
game but I finally just figured out now
some explain it to me on Twitter
I just start tweeting about
go and you know I I don't I don't
know who the fuck is who here
you know and
I had this weird thing like I didn't
know who to root for because there was
something so fucking funny to me
if the Russians won the World Cup
I would just would have been so awesome.
Listening.
Two people losing their shit over here
and getting all wound up again saying
that they you know tampered with the
election over here you know and then
everybody just starts yelling at each
other again it's just I was looking
forward to that. You know just
adding to the fucking heat out here.
But anyways it was an incredible game
and I can not fucking I root for Croatia.
You know although every time they cut
to the Russians in the crowd I was just
like you know those are
some good looking people.
You know there's really no middle ground
with Russians so you know what I mean.
Already Eastern European.
So either they'd look like
fucking supermodels or they
look like it's still like
medieval times.
You don't mean.
I mean they got some women over there
that looked like they could easily fucking
impress some NFL scouts you know in
the in the we know the NFL Combine when
they're pushing up to 25. How many
reps they can do much. You know.
Course they wouldn't get drafted after
the 40 but I'm just saying that they.
You know. But then they got some other
ones it's like Oh my God. Gorgeous.
I'm fucking with you I'm not saying
that you know there's not a lot of weird
looking Americans
but that was one of the really cool
things looking at that thinking of all the
fucking bullshit that goes
on at a political level.
You know with the missiles and all of
that shit and then just to watch all these
Russians losing their fucking minds every
time Russia would score a goal so long
story short that's their game with
the Croatian crowd. Same thing.
Fucking really good looking people that
I mentioned that I'm gonna be doing an
Eastern European tour at the beginning
of next year you know and I will be
bringing all of Europe fuckin good looking
numbers down a half a degree during
the time in your fucking country.
Please come up to me in your native tongue
and tell me that you can fix my bald
problem balding problem.
It's a bowling ball that
you can yeah I can fix that.
I am the greatest in Transylvania.
That's why I approach people on the
street with my fuckin business card.
I'm sweating as I'm watching this fucking
game and like I'm doing the typical
American thing like.
I can't think you will do this. Look at
this level. Fuck you you'll be sued soon.
Do you love doing that shit and all of a
sudden Croatia scores a goal and I just
don't. I couldn't control myself.
I just fucking lost my shit right.
And then Russia comes back immediately.
I believe I watched some of the
games I forget. They fuckin scored
and fucking the Russian fans are going
nuts and I'm like all these motherfuckers
you know you know me I'm
always good spirits today.
Vladimir Lenin and Putin you know he's
got it he's got the fucking he's got the
it's got the invisible hand you know and
then Croatia scores
and it's fucking 2 to 1 there's like
barely any time left and I just I almost
made my daughter jump out of the chair
in the other room I yelled so loud when
they scored and I was like Holy fuck this
is gonna be on bleep that fucking guy
number 10.
Number 10 is a beast of Croatia right.
And there's like no time left and all
of a sudden Russia gets like a fucking
corner kick and I was just sitting there
I had my hands over my mouth just going
like Oh no no
come on come on.
And then he fucking kicks
it this beautiful whatever
the fuck you call it you
know it was like a pass into the slot
you know in hockey like a sausage pass
just right over everybody's fucking
head and it just goes right to this one
Russian dude who just makes it glances
it off his head into the back of the net
and I just go.
And every time I yelled
I've surprised myself.
I can't believe how
fucking into this game I
saw my wife and my and my daughter
are getting ready to leave.
And I'm like I'm sorry I. We can't leave.
I have to see the end of this game.
She's like Are you serious.
Like is that this is yet another
thing that you're fucking into.
I'm like Yeah I go it's the shoot out
whatever the penalty whatever fuck they
call it and I sat there like literally
like I was like that Tarkanian guy like
chewing on a fucking towel.
I was in the kitchen yo because I had to
keep you know leave in the fucking room
and I had like the fucking towel you
dry dishes with to make my wife is gone
you're going to throw that in the hamper
I'm like I'm fucking non on the thing
and just the level the
level of fucking pressure.
And if you miss one of those penalty
kicks and your team only loses by one like
you just get shit for the rest of your
life you know I mean there was a guy in
Columbia and they don't know if he got
killed because of that but me it's pretty
fucking suspicious.
It was an incredible game.
And like
it's safe to say that I 100 percent get
it and I actually love the game now.
There I said it. I love soccer.
It's a fucking great game.
I finally get it.
I fucking get it you know.
And then how great the World Cup is.
Where it's truly is a world championship.
And then what's great is if you lose
okay that other team can talk shit to you
for the next three fucking years and
it's once every four years but you're not
even guarantee that
you're going to get in.
So when you get to that fucking
close when you lose. Now I get it.
Now I get why I'm sitting there watching
grown man cry who are in their 50s and
60s because they're sitting there going
like it's not going to happen in my
lifetime.
I'm going to die without ever see them
holding up an astoundingly small trophy
for a true World Championship to see
how big the fucking Stanley Cup is.
That's 30 teams 30 one whatever
the fuck they're up to.
It's not the whole world.
You got the whole world.
Why the fuck is the trophy so small.
It's so funny when they win it and
they all try to run around with it.
They're all like know trying to hold it up
there like bumping heads and shit like
they keep their cake they should make it
bigger. You know what. That's classic
fucking. That's how an American thinks.
That's how we think you know
bigger is better. It is.
And you know something as much as you
guys sit there and you shit on us in the
back of your heads you're jealous of it.
You're jealous how fat we get.
He jealous how big they make the
jeans of you and your jealousy.
You could actually be that fat still
get down the fucking street because you
guys are over there driving around in
your fucking cow path you know past all
your ruins in your fucking
castles and all that shit.
Why am I in such a mood right now.
I gotta turn the light on the fucking
sun went down as I'm talking here.
Hang on.
The world is gone
got the whole world in his hand.
He's got the whole world in its hands.
It's gonna be the first song to teach a
kid right. It's gonna be it's religious.
Easy
all right.
Let's look at some of the advertising
here for this week's show.
So congratulations to Croatia.
I mean Jesus and then there were four
England versus Croatia tomorrow France
versus Belgium.
I'm sorry on Tuesday.
Well I guess that will be tomorrow
my time units France first Belgium on
Wednesday.
I'm working both days so that the tape
the games and hopefully not somebody on
the fucking set will say something.
God damn it.
What the fuck you going to do anyways.
Let's read some of the some of
the fucking advertising here.
This is so weird that I hate reading
out loud so much that I get upset when I
have a lot of advertising.
It's actually money.
I know but have to read Dollar Shave
Club everybody Dollar Shave Club delivers
everything you need to look
feels man smell your best
Dollar Shave Club is everything you
need to get ready in the bathroom and
delivers everything you need to
look feel and smell your best.
Do they just write that twice. Am I like
fucking havin a stroke. You name it.
You name it.
I mean a lady.
I got pink screens being there you
name it they should have read this shit
shampoo conditioner body wash toothpaste
hair gel even a wipe that alleviate
tush feel and tingly clean you know out
of all the complimentary gifts I would
have loved to have gotten that one all
of Dolly's shame clubs products are made
with top shelf ingredients that won't
break your budget you if you feel the
difference.
Plus shipping is included with all your
membership it is a great way to touch to
touch to try a bunch
Yeah that's how do I combined try and
bunch some I got touch I just saw the c h
of dollars shaved clubs products slow
down bill for just five bucks you can get
their daily essentials start a cassette
daily essentials starters that standby
you smell so ventilating because of my
daily essential starters that it comes
with body cleanser one wipe char
re they're amazing but wipes
just so funny but but it's such I can
not attractive for you so blunt but but
you can't say amazing ass wipes because
people get called you fucking ass wipe.
I'm an amazing asked why you know
rectum wipes you know daddy yeah they're
worlds famous shave but
that's what the French are this shit
I mean come on man it's an ass area
and their best razor this
6 blade executive do you
realize if England and France
play each other in the world cup final
will probably start another fucking war
over there in Europe you know someone
will bring up Napoleon or some King George
shit whatever the fuck those people.
And so he's got the powdered wigs with
them and add in shampoo toothpaste or
anything else you need for the bathroom
check it all out a jolly shave club job
crime slash ba that's jolly shave club
dot com slash burn all right that's one
frame bridge everybody I get four reads
here in honor of the four people left in
the world cup.
All right that first
one went out to France.
All right.
This one goes out to fucking who
they're play in Belgium frame bridge.
If you've been listening to this show
you've heard me talk about frame bridge.
They make it super easy and affordable
to frame your favorite things from Art
France and posters to the travel
photos sitting on your phone.
Here's how it works.
Just go to frame bridge dot com and
upload your photo or they'll send you a
package to safely mail
in your physical pieces.
GROSS fuckin Syracuse preview your
item online in any frame style.
Choose your favorite or get
free recommendations from
their talented designers.
That's for me.
I can't pick it out the black spray.
They're the expert team at frame bridge
will custom frame your item and deliver
your finished piece directly
to your door ready to hang.
I just fuck and have an unbelievable
amount of empathy for someone who's gonna
sit there on the phone with some dope
like me goes I Why did you picture frame.
But I don't know what color.
Well let's take a look at it.
Well your parents are white.
The shit state is brown.
I don't know.
I'm thinking orange instead
of the hundreds you'd pay
at framing and a framing
store.
Their prices started thirty nine
dollars and all shipping is free.
Plus my listeners will get 15 percent
off their first order at frame bridge dot
com when they use my code per
recommended editorializing
gave your personal experience
using frame bridge.
I'm doing it right now.
I haven't got it back yet.
All right but I got this very romantic
beautiful picture of me and my wife in
front of our favorite cafe in Paris.
All right.
And then we have other ones with our
little fucking little fuckin bugbear.
Front of the Eiffel Tower and
the fucking arc de triomphe.
You know my parents came to London I
got some pictures of them were near the
Tower Bridge.
I'm getting all of that stuff done I
can't wait to see what they do. All right.
Okay. Who's Ken who. I just outed myself
because you were like Bill then Bill why.
I thought you said you
can pick out the frames.
Did you talk to somebody over there. No.
I had Andrew do all of this. All right.
I can comment on the finished product.
Call to Action must re get started today.
Frame your photos or send the perfect
gift for weddings birthdays and special
events. Go to frame bridge dot
com and use the promo code br.
You'll save an additional 50 percent off
your first or just go to frame bridge
dot com promo Cooper
friendly shark promo code per
all right.
This next one's for Croatia
where I say Crowe you say Asia express
VPN with all the recent news about data
hacks and breaches.
It's hard not to worry about digital
privacy. What happened recently.
Was there a big one.
I didn't hear about it again.
You know I watch my TV my
new show 7 77 Sunset Strip.
No matter what you do online your
mobile is that volcano still erupting.
Your mobile carrier and Internet
service provider track it all.
That's why it's so hot out here.
Every website you visit every
email you send it's ridiculous.
So take back your privacy by using
express VPN express VPN is the world's
leading greatest VPN provider.
They let you secure the use your internet
without being tracked by anyone not
even the North Koreans express VPN keeps
online activity private and anonymous
while you browse email download or
stream express VPN is great for streaming
content. You can even use it to watch the
World Cup without a cable subscription.
How cool is that.
They're easy to use app encrypts all
Internet data and hides the IP address
protecting the entire connection express
VPN costs less than seven bucks a month
and runs seamlessly in the background
of your computer phone or tablet every
time you use the Internet without express
VPN you're putting sensitive data at
risk.
Call the action take back your Internet
privacy today and find out how you can
get three free months go to express VPN
dot com cyber That's E XP r e ss express
VPN dot com No I suppose e XP r e s as
VPN dot com slash burn for three months
with a one year package visit express
VPN dot com search bar to learn more.
And lastly but not legally for England
stamps dot com.
Create your own stamps dot com account
in minutes online with no equipment to
lease and no long term commitments
click print mail and you're done.
It's convenient it's easy it's reliable
it's efficient it's like that wonderful
fucking easy check up the street stamps
dot com brings all the amazing services
of the United States Postal Service
right to your fingertips tips by print
official U.S. postage for any letter any
package any class mail using your own
computer or stamps star cards makes it
easy they'll send you a digital scale
automatically calculates extra postage
stamps dot com will even help you decide
the best class of mail
based on your needs.
Now need to lease an expensive postage
meter and there are no long term
commitments.
Are you stamps dot com whenever I send
out my posters which I am sending out on
this tour.
I am a moron if I can figure out if I
can figure out how to do it so can you.
And right now you too can enjoy the stamps
dot com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale go to stamps
dot com.
Click on the mike for the top the whole
page and type in BR That stamps dot com.
Enter br.
All righty then.
All right hang on a
second hang on a second.
All right let's get on.
Well we can't get onto the letters
I have to talk about the F1 race.
That was in Great Britain
back to back.
I'd have to say these are the two most
exciting races I've seen since I've been
watching which has been Monaco 2016.
I've seen almost every race since then.
What a fucking race.
Lewis Hamilton was trying to get the
pole position for like the eighth fucking
time in a row there I think he's
won like the last six or seven.
He always dominates there.
He had a rough showing didn't even
finish it it did not finish his last one
wherever the fuck they were.
I remember in Austria and you knew
Mercedes was going to come back strong.
So the race starts all right.
I believe Lewis Hamilton was in first
Vettel was in second Kimi Reagan
and was somewhere in there.
Normally they go into
the first fucking turn.
Lewis Hamilton something you
hardly ever see has a bad start.
Fatal blows by Hamilton
gets his fucking car going.
I don't understand did he pop the clutch
I don't get how they have a bad start.
I don't understand that Atari fuckin
steering wheel that they're doing there I
don't get it.
There is no clutch anymore.
I don't even know what they did get
a little paddle thing there I have no
fucking idea but sometimes they don't
hit the right button and they just go on
too slow. I don't know but
they blame the driver right.
So anyway so they get into the first
fucking turn and all of a sudden factory
boats comes screaming in out of
nowhere Venables in first place
Lewis Hamilton's all of a sudden in third.
I was like no fucking way.
And then out of nowhere you just see
all this smoke and shit and now just go
nuts in Lewis Hamilton got
hit by Kimi reckoning and
any fuckin spun out and he went from
like one Turner to turns from being first
in the race to being last and
it was just like What the fuck.
And then I believe at
that point it was Vettel.
Bow ties and then Kimi reckoning or
maybe max for Stamper went up there.
But you know the Red Bull team was right
there by the way the United States the
fucking Haas team we were we've qualified
fifth and sixth we were killing it
until we fucking slammed into each other
like assholes and took ourselves out of
the points
and we may be at one point I think we
came in 10th means fuck it sucked but we
do it better than we
are doing better than I.
That's the team that I want really want
to win anything anybody has to do with
American racing but where
we're having a great season.
If we could just quit fucking
up and bought our plowing ahead
so
Lewis Hamilton is not out of the race
he gets his car going again and which is
one of my favorite things.
What a great driver like him Sebastian
Vettel gets knocked all over the back of
the race. Then you get to
watch him go through the field.
And he was driving go in my car and
messed up it's messed up the rear and they
go No you find your phone you're fine
and he just tears through the whole field
basically up until the top five and then
even when he got top five he's still
like 25 seconds behind
that's how superior basically Red Bull
really Mercedes Ferrari is and then Red
Bull and
so Mercedes adopted this.
We're just going to stop once like
an hour if you're not into this shit.
It's actually like fascinating
like petting and all of that stuff.
You can win and lose it.
And long story fucking short
is by the end of the race.
Like the final five laps.
Because Mercedes only pitted one time
and Ferrari's period at least twice
because I think one time they went in
like I never understand out works well
with the safety car out there or whatever
the fuck they call it pace car some
shit right.
But anyways all of a sudden with five
laps left it's felt terrible task is in
first place
Sebastian Vettel is right behind him
with fresher tires what's his face.
Lewis Hamilton driving like a maniac once
again with not as fresh tires because
they only stopped once so they're all
fucking chewed up and they're right on his
ass.
Is that fucking psycho.
Kimmy Regan who I fucking love drives
like a maniac and a 10 second penalty by
the way because they said he smashed
into Lewis Hamilton he didn't need to do
that and he was yelling at his fucking
pit crew and all that shit was fucking
great. So they're all driving
like absolute fucking maniacs.
And once again I'm screaming at the
TV Young once again at a sport I never
thought I would be into.
And unfortunately for Vanna like his
his tires just crapped out and he just
didn't have enough grip and
I'm sorry you felt terrible to us.
I'm sorry his tires just crapped out and
Vettel was able to duck underneath them
and then he then he gave way to Lewis
Hamilton which I thought was really cool
that Hamilton was trying
to stay on his ass.
They just didn't have the fucking tyres.
And what's his face.
Bolton set it up.
I think it went all the way down Fifth
or Sixth but the final was Sebastian
Vettel for Ferrari. Lewis Hamilton
from Mercedes and that can be reckoned
on the podium there was two
Ferraris and a Mercedes.
Sebastian Vettel is now eight points up
and the Ferrari team I think is like 20
points up for the year and we've got
two more races before the summer break.
There couldn't be any closer it's
going to be fucking great fuck
anyways.
Jesus Christ.
By the way I just hit pause there.
Coughing What flick another
nine fucking seconds.
I must read some advertising here.
So anyways the next one I believe is
I think it's in Germany or is it the
Hungarian or is it the next two. But I
got to think a lot of jeeps coming up.
I hope I didn't fucking make my stupid
recorder is it fucking not.
Isn't recording those things because
sometimes it gets bumped down in priority
or another fact that
works. All right. Okay.
In regard to Eastern European tour.
Dear Bill you mentioned
planning East European tour.
I just want to make just one as a mention
to think about visiting one of former
Yugoslavian countries in the parklands.
If this plan moves forward I emailed you
from Belgrade Serbia but anything here
like Croatia Bosnia or even
Slovenia can work for local fans.
Check out some stats.
We have the most site visits or something
as it would be interesting to see you
live somewhere near.
Stand up is still relatively rising here
but I am sure it might be interesting
for you to visit if you are around here.
Dude I will go there and fucking
eat my balls in a second.
What am I ever gonna go there.
I'll be close enough that you
can jump on a train. All right.
Your papers please.
However the fuck it works over there
you know Eastern Europe scares me.
That is still behind the communist
bloc like for most of my life.
So
then I know you know once Russia went
out of there you guys kind of picked up
some Hatfield McCoy shit that you.
Hadn't finished you know got a little
crazy there with the fucking genocide
stuff you know get a little
nuts over there so you know
you guys don't fuck around over
there is what I'm trying to say.
It's not like you're going to Canada.
Oh hey how you doing.
You know it's not like someone loves sex.
I feel like I'm gonna go over there
it's going to happen like that same vibe
like Belfast had where I was just like
if you didn't know some shit went down
the second you go eat sleep well some
fucking shit went down here and you just
immediately act accordingly like I
will not be fucking with anybody here.
All the best for you and your family.
I will.
I'm very very excited to see that part
of the world and we are putting it
together. I wouldn't bring it up
if we weren't putting it together.
All right. Okay. Possible Eastern
European tour. Another one.
Hey chief.
I was just listening to
your latest podcast July 2nd
where you mentioned putting
together an Eastern European tour.
Look at this look at all the fans.
This is two people.
I knew this tour be successful.
Hopefully you'll have the balls to come
to Belgrade Serbia so I can see you
perform in person.
Well the second you tell me I need balls
to go where the fuck are you from. Yeah.
Go fuck yourself no go in there.
Why don't I what I need
to have balls to go there.
Don't even talk about the weather.
It's not Siberia it's Serbia because
I'm going to go there and take a fucking
farm tool to the side of my head.
I don't need that shit.
We had vampires are considered as
I'm sure you'll have a blast here.
I like how he scares the fuck out of
me. I there. Go go to the waterpark.
Also I don't know when you're playing to
do this tour but I'd recommend sometime
between September and November.
Hopefully you'll put some more
specific information out of this plan.
So now I was thinking like January
or February. Why is that a bad time.
What happens in those months anyway.
Love your oh lows during January we
everybody stays inside and they let the
inmates run down the street.
It's like running of bulls with murder.
Anyways love your shtick and wacky antics
with the occasion random high jinks.
Rock on you crazy bastard right.
Just where you're talking.
I think I'll be fine
if I go over all right.
Obama's Money Hi Bill.
I'm eager to get the shit
kicked out of me on this one.
He signed a book deal you unread
douche Oh stop it stop it.
I don't want to hear this shit.
I don't want to hear this dude. He's
going to go around and he's got to do it.
He had 70 million dollars
with a fucking tour dates.
He also had that you selectively
UN reading douche bag.
Don't tell me he fucked you. He had a
fucking 900 million dollar book deal.
Obama 65 million dollar book deal.
All right.
Wait a second wait a second.
Now I'm going to fucking
hit you back with my shit.
Obama
speaking dates.
Money tour.
Here we go. Come on man. Big
number big no big number.
Michelle Obama tickets
for two thousand eighty.
Barack Obama four hundred
thousand dollars. Speaking fees.
Reveal what few.
Here we go.
Obama secures eight hundred
grand for two speaking
and we think he's talking to.
These go to a homeless shelter.
The reason many of us have been critical
Barack Obama's outrageous for those TV
ads is it robs us of a fantasy that
sooner or later the first black president
was going to use his considerable
powers in or out of office to help the
economic ravages of the poor who
are disproportionately black.
But you know a white
person probably wrote this.
I want to know who he's talking to huh.
Who the fuck has 400 grand
to throw at this fucking guy.
They're all. I don't I don't know
how to talk to you fucking assholes.
So am I really supposed to sit here and
I'm supposed to think that these fucking
guys like everybody with the blue tie.
I just don't buy it.
I don't fucking buy it. All right. OK.
Sixty five billion dollar book
deal. OK. After taxes sir.
After taxes and all the bullshit that'll
probably be about 30 billion bucks.
And I guarantee fucking T you he is gonna
be worth when it's all said and done
about 200 million bucks.
OK. And it's not going to be because
he wrote a fucking book. All right.
He's also going to go out and they do
these speaking engagements to all these
corporations that they'll
pay them 400 fucking grand.
And these are the same people that got
him into office and he went in there and
did what the fuck they wanted.
And this is just them
washing their bribe money.
I mean honestly dude what changed when
he was in office that everybody is so
enamored with.
Did we stop torturing people
down in Guantanamo that we
fucking end the war over
there.
Are we finally going like hey wait a
minute ISIS doesn't have a plane or a boat
why are we acting like
Germany got back together
now it's the same fucking thing.
It's the same god damn.
It's the same guy with a
different colored tie. All right.
I will fuckin read up on this.
Hi Bill.
Love these shows you
work in our little world.
Our most recent party you talked about
the House Obama just bought and wondered
where the money came from.
Here's a piece that explains it.
It doesn't
it doesn't.
Sixty five million dollars you don't turn
around and you're only going to get 30
million dollars of that
OK.
And then you're gonna go out buy an 80
billion dollar fucking house you're gonna
pay at the 30 year note on that paying
interest on that because you just
basically got 30 million
dollars after taxes.
That makes no fucking sense
all right.
And also I would say I would actually be
willing to suggest that I am a fucking
paranoid maniac that the information
that you're going to they're not going to
tell you.
Can someone explain to me how did the
Clintons become worth hundreds of millions
of dollars.
Let me guess they both wrote a book for
one hundred million dollars each and
they what they don't pay taxes.
And that was it.
And then other than that they like Jimmy
Carter driving around the world fucking
you know
building houses for the poor.
I never claimed sir to be 100
percent fucking read up on this shit.
I'm not even 2 percent read
up on it but neither are you.
OK.
This is not a piece that explains it.
This is a piece that just shows this
guy cashing the fucking sixty million is
the gross
he's gonna get about 30 million bucks
that's it because he's got to kick in
for this never ending war too. All right.
So now he's got 30 million bucks.
He owes 82 million.
Like what is the fucking
payment on that a month.
Now he's going to go around and he's gonna
give all these fucking speeches. Okay.
And at schools do not
have the fucking you know
I would say Ivy League schools some of
these bigger fucking schools maybe they
have that but generally speaking they
go round and they talk to these fucking
these corporations.
Who got him into fucking office.
Hey dude what the fuck me what do you
do with it but putting you know every
fucking one of them. I don't I think
the whole fucking thing is weird.
It's all weird it's all weird that he's
a public servant and blah blah blah blah.
And in the end of the rainbow you were
two hundred fucking million dollars and
you're living in the same neighborhood
is all those corporate cunts who pour
shit into the fucking water supply.
Like the fact that that doesn't bother
you on any goddamn level and you're going
to just sit that way yet you
get 65 million for a book.
I mean there you go.
I'm satisfied with that.
I don't think the political
system is corrupt at all.
I don't think it's a bad thing that now
corporations can dump unlimited amount
of funds into presidential candidates.
I don't think that that influences their
decisions on foreign policy whatsoever.
I don't know.
Hey you know what sir.
Agree to fucking disagree.
All right.
Anyways I've been rather restless and
despite the fact that I disagree with you
I will say that there are
assholes on both sides.
However I however believe that there is
a lot to be said about how one conducts
themselves which is why I
side with Hillary over Trump.
Yeah I love you people who like it's
how you conduct yourself as long as you
continue murdering innocent people.
It's like it's not a problem.
But but is so eloquent
when they give a speech
do you know why the president
ages the way they do.
It's because of the dead bodies.
That's why it's not the economy.
It's not the sketches on SNL which is
what always cracks me up when you see like
people in Hollywood talking about how
they want to run for president you're
basically saying that you're so fucked
in their head that that you will that you
want to go to bed put your head on the
pillow go and like that I do the right
thing we thought they were the enemy.
It turned out to be a family.
There were children there.
And you have to fucking go to bed.
And then the next day fuck and
smile and give some goddamn speech.
It is the most fucked that maybe maybe
they deserve the money. I don't know.
Maybe I'm oversimplifying I am.
I always oversimplify you know what sir
I agree with you. You're probably right.
You know I think that's how we
got the house. He wrote a book.
He could be declared duck.
This chick was sucking my cock clubs
to do forget about Andrew Dice Clay.
God bless you.
All right.
Podcast topic table wondering if on an
upcoming podcast you can talk about how
your views may or may not have
changed on being a stay at home mom
that you are a parent yourself.
No they haven't changed
they haven't changed.
I think everybody exaggerates how
difficult their fucking Jarvis
alright. Listen. Being a single parent
is difficult.
I would say they would probably
unbelievably fucking difficult.
However if you fucking
married you know what I mean.
It's and you got one kid.
It's not that hard.
The first three months.
Yeah.
You're hallucinating you know but you
get somebody to help you out a friend a
family member something to help you out
see state that whole fucking thing where
people try to do it themselves this is
goddamn and it's fucking insane it's
fucking insane. That's not that
people didn't do that back in the day.
They say it takes a village to raise a
child back in the day you didn't fuckin
move to the other side of the goddamn
forest you just built a fucking log cabin
right next to your parents. That was
it. They came over they helped you out.
Follow a grizzly bear.
OK.
Now my views have have not changed.
Other than that I gave you answer to when
I watched my kid I'm fucking psyched.
I love it.
I have a great goddamn time.
We play games were screaming and yelling
with throwing balls all over the living
room.
And you know
I don't what the problem is.
You know my buddy was bitching about
something talking money or do something
difficult.
I said Do you realize there's probably
some guy from Cuba right now that you
know
made a boat out of the discarded desk
and he's using a fucking sport coat is a
sail.
Trying to get into this fucking country
risking the fact that he's gonna get cut
sent back and God knows what the fuck out.
I still don't know what exactly
is the problem with your day.
It's what I would say ma'am is it's about
perspective which is what that bit was
about.
I'm not saying it's not a challenging
job I'm not saying it's not an important
job.
I just said it's not the most
difficult job on the planet.
I would say that that people who fucking
were trying when the lava was coming
down at their house and they didn't have
lava insurance I would say some more
trying day than when your kid
just would not stop crying.
You know
your hero could not stop crying when that
fucking lava is at the front to help.
Should I tell my
boyfriend I'm a prostitute
OK.
Now you and I know sometimes these these
these e-mails get a little fuckin not
believable. Like what am I
supposed to do with this shit here.
Is this actually sir.
Help. Exclamation point.
Should I tell my boyfriend
I'm a prostitute.
All right.
What do I do here people do I ignore
this to actually act like this is real.
All right let's wait until
Dear Billy ball Baggins.
I'm a 25 year old semi single
lady living in the Netherlands OK.
I've got good qualifications
masters degree in social.
Well sounds like an outgoing am I going
to argue and try to treat other people
with kindness and respect.
God bless you.
You're the prostitute
with a heart of gold Adam.
You really have a master's degree.
I'd really like to build a special
relationship in my life and I'm currently
dating a nice guy from Brazil.
Oh boy. But there's a catch.
For the past three years I've
been working in the sex industry.
I like my job make good money and
always practice safe sex. Oh boy oh boy.
Get out of that business sweetheart.
I don't want to quit as it would mean
busting my ass to some corporate job
working for the man.
Yikes.
You can't just be a stripper
you know.
No offense to strippers but Jesus Christ.
You gotta shake your ass a little bit
you know close yourself off in the green
room and just walk away
like it never happened.
For me it's not a big deal to balance my
job in a loving relationship as I don't
find the work side of things
emotionally intimate at all.
However my boyfriend seldom
sees it the same way.
My boyfriend's I am sure if I should be
honest with my new potential boyfriend
about my profession
I'm unsure if I should be.
Normally I'm very honest and upfront my
boyfriend's about my job and normally it
kills the relationship I see.
I'm starting to wonder if honesty is
really the best policy as the truth always
seems to add extra pressure in the
strained the relationship and it hurts me
when I get attached to people and they
finish with me. What do you think.
I hope you and Nia had a nice time
in Paris and go fuck yourself.
We had a great time all right.
Okay if this is true sweetheart.
Yeah. If you want to find a
loving relationship I think
you need to stop being a
prostitute.
Okay.
You know.
I understand.
You know nobody understands.
Not want to ending up in
a cubicle more than me.
But I mean it's a fucking dangerous job.
You know it's a very dangerous job.
It's a bunch of creeps out there and I
practice safe sex but you know there's
always problems.
It's just you know.
I don't know.
I don't know something I'm looking at
this as a you know what that Puritan
American fucking viewpoint.
I don't know if you're
free you're over there man.
I don't know what the deal is but let's
say I could actually handle the fact the
physical aspects of the girl I was
dating being a prostitute which I could.
Let's just say I could
I would be so worried.
Every time she went out that someone
was gonna beat her up or kill her.
I mean you're in the sex industry.
It's a fucking horrible industry.
You know I would
I think you know at least I would be
worried about is how I tell this fucking
guy.
I mean the sex industry.
I would be more worried.
How the fuck do I get
out of the sex industry.
Because what's going to happen is
eventually you're going to be an old
prostitute all right.
And I don't know what you're investing
your money in Bitcoin or you know your
own whorehouse. I have no idea
what you're doing here but like
you know then all of a sudden
there's this big gap in your resume.
Well you weren't in a cubicle you're
trying to get a corporate job and you're
like you know what did
you do from 2010 to 2021.
Oh I I.
I had sex for money.
Oh.
Oh okay. Well all right. I don't
think we have any more questions.
I mean
you know assuming this is all true
I would love it if you
got out of that industry.
Just get out of it. You know what I mean.
There's easy money in my business too.
You know I could go fucking do it
like a whore myself out you know.
But you know what. You always leave a
piece of yourself there back in that room.
I don't know you have a tremendous
attitude. I mean you make it sound fun.
I love it that you know don't
get emotionally attached
to making good fucking
money.
You know this is when any woman group
would be like That's because she's so numb
from the Zapotec be that both you know
they start throwing their thoughts into
your fucking head.
I don't know how you're wired it might
be fucking true it might not be true.
I don't have any if I don't know
if this is way above my pay grade.
I have no idea but I you should fucking
tell somebody that you're you know
having sex for money.
You know you probably want to
know that because it is dangerous
you know there's FTD or
all that shit out there.
Yeah I guess I would I would you know I
would tell fuck it you know I guess you
can continue being a prostitute you're
soul mates gonna be the person you don't
have to lie to and you can't
accept me for who I am. You know.
All right. I don't know what I got to
do to get rid of this fucking called.
It just came on slow.
My doctor was telling me if it comes out
fast it goes away fast comes on slow it
goes way slow I guess that's
what the fuck's going on here.
But anyways that is the podcast.
Good luck to all four teams
left to the World Cup.
Good luck to that prostitute
and Brazilian guy.
God bless the United States of America
and congratulations to Obama for signing
a 900 million dollar book deal.
That's how he got that house.
That's how he's gonna pay for it.
All you need is 30 million bucks
or 80 to fuck it.
If I get a 60 million
dollar fucking book deal
and I was gonna get was 30 million
bucks out of it I was getting 40 grand a
night.
I still wouldn't go out buy an 82 million
dollar house I wouldn't fucking do it
in a two million dollar house
is a fuckin white elephant.
No offense to the Obamas.
All right.
I mean when you turn around to sell
that thing I mean there's like point one
percent of people that can
actually fucking afford it.
You got to hope that they're
in the goddamn market.
Do you think of flight drones are it
for old time's sake.
Oh I was a low blow see Bill this is
why people think you voted for Trump.
I don't like making fun of Trump it's
too fucking easy there's two idiots in
paying attention to him it's too
fucking depressing. You know.
Oh by the way that I got a of that dopey
Brad thing on fucking Instagram and I
can't get over that clip that little
shit yelled at that bouncer the bouncer
goes can I get out of my face you little
shit or whatever and the kid is so
beside himself.
He's. Oh my God. Oh my God. Do you have
any idea what the fuck my dad does.
I cannot believe that a man
said that to another man.
Do you have any idea what the fuck my dad
does it's like why is about talking to
your dad their son I'm talking to you.
What the fuck do you do.
Other than buy little shirts
but when I love you I've watched
that video so many times.
After that he fuckin throws that little
shit which is so savage satisfying to
watching to watch when you listen to his
friends danger say ah do you are fucked
you are just fucked up dude and the kid
gets up in like oh why does he know some
Thai commando what's going down and
he goes you just fucked up there.
They all walked away right but they
were so convinced that this bouncer was
fucked.
It's the point I was sitting there like
I was feel like unsatisfied.
Like do I want to know
what the fuck your dad does
do you have any idea what
the fuck my dad does.
I just always says Oh my
God oh my god oh my God.
He is like are you seriously
challenging me right now.
Do you have any idea what the
fuck might that what does he do.
Does he torture people for the
CIA what the fuck does he do.
Oh my God. So he's gonna animate that
that bouncer sitting in the chair.
Know torture is always like
the fucking tools of you.
There's that little shit I told you
when he told you not to push me.
My little polo shirt.
All right that's it.
I apologize to Obama and all presidents.
Evidently they just do book deals.
Just make 40 grand a
night giving speeches to
banking colored conglomerates
and that type of shit.
No they don't they go around a homeless
shelter so they all scrape together
fucking nickels that they they pay
for that. I have no fucking idea.
And you know what.
Neither does the guy who I love
how he looked up one fucking thing.
That's why I just I love doing
a podcast as I get a good day.
I'm not that dumb these people just
as dumb as me you know would know.
Jimmy door. I could have Jimmy that. I
mean fucking Jimmy doing this podcast.
I'm going to save this.
I'm going to save this fuckin question.
I'm going to read it to Jimmy door.
All right. Oh my God. Oh my God.
Do you have any idea what
the fuck Jimmy door reads.
Jimmy door is gonna be my dad on this
question so I can win because I want to
win. I don't wanna be right. I just want
to win. That's what it's about right.
All right. Have a great week. You fuckin
cunts. I'll check in on you on Thursday.